Student Brian Yee asks, we’re using python two in this class but python three exists,
are we – is what we’re learning outdated? Does it not help us in the real world?
Okay, so fair enough question.
There is a newer version of python and almost everything that we’ve learned in this class,
it doesn’t matter whether you’re using python or a Java Script or scheme or C or Java,
any program or language, the basic concepts that we’ve learned really apply
to all of those languages in the same way.
Now, developing skills as a programmer is useful to learn different languages
and different languages have slightly different ways of doing things
and we talked in the previous question about the pythonic way
being the best way to do something in python to really take advantage of
the design and the style that python programmers expect.
Python three is different from python two and in some ways it’s not that different.
So almost everything that you’ve written in this class would work
in python three and would be the same way to write it in python three,
some things wouldn’t. And most code today,
python two is still used more widely than python three.
There is some incompatibilities in python three that mean it’s very hard to move libraries
that were written for python two to work in python three
and the infrastructure that we’re using is all working in python two,
not in python three. So that’s the real reason that we use python two
for this class instead of python three.
But essentially everything that you’ve learned would be the same
and would be very easy to transfer if you start writing python three code.
Some things will be a little different and probably the most notable thing
that would be different is print would work differently.
So the code that you’ve written that uses print would not work in python three,
you’d have to add extra parentheses for that.
But otherwise everything would really be the same,
there is no concepts that would be different, it’s just a matter of different things
defined slightly differently in different languages.